Hello.
I'm Dana Bash in Washington,
where the state of our union
is thankful,
thankful that an American
detained in a Russian penal
colony is finally home.
You're looking
at New pictures of Brittney Griner,
the WNBA superstar
who touched down on American soil early
Friday morning.
She reunited with her wife,
Cheryl, and was taken immediately
for a medical evaluation.
President Biden celebrated her return
and now faces questions
about his decision to trade.
Convicted and
convicted Russian arms dealer
Viktor Bout in exchange for the WNBA star
and the American left behind in Russia.
Paul Wieland,
who has been held prisoner there
for nearly four years,
My guess now is working to free
wheeling and dozens of Americans
held hostage and other foreign nations.
And he has a pretty good track record.
Special envoy
special presidential envoy,
I should say, for hostage affairs
Roger Carstens
helped secure Griner's release
and was there to greet her
and bring her home.
Thank you so much.
For joining me this morning.
What an ordeal and what a saga.
Let's start
with the sort of the personal.
You flew to the dump to UAE.
You welcomed her on the tarmac.
What was the moment like
for both of you
and what was it like for her
or specifically?
It's always kind of an exciting moment
when you jump on the other country's
plane and walk up to a person,
in this case, Brittney.
And I'll tell you what I told her.
I said, Brittney,
my name is Ambassador Roger. Carstens.
I'm with the U.S.
Department of State
on behalf of the president
of the United States, Joe Biden,
and Secretary of State Tony Blinken.
I'm here to take you home.
And at that moment,
I think
every person finally starts
to realize that it's going to happen.
It's setting in.
Certainly, Brittney felt that way.
And at that point,
we have to go through a little more
of the choreography
to get her on the plane
usually takes about 3 minutes.
But here's what I wouldn't mind
telling you.
When she finally got onto the US plane,
I said, Brittney,
you must have been through a lot
over the last ten months.
Here's your seat.
Please feel free to decompress.
Will give you your space.
And she said, oh, no,
I've been in prison for ten months now
listening to Russian. I want to talk.
But first of all, who are these guys?
And she moved right past me
and went to every member on that crew,
looked him in the eyes,
shook their hands
and asked about them,
got their names,
making a personal connection with them.
It was really amazing.
And then later on, on an 18 hour flight,
she probably spent 12 hours
just just talking.
We talked about everything under the sun,
and I was left
with the impression
that this is an intelligent,
passionate, compassionate, humble,
interesting person, a patriotic person,
but above all, authentic
I hate the fact that I had to meet her
in this manner,
but I actually felt blessed
having had a chance to get to know her.
You said that she wanted to talk.
Did you talk specifically
about the experience
in the Russian penal colony?
She did.
I'd hate to steal her thunder
because it's her story to tell,
but she
she spoke at length about what
it was like to go undergo that
ten month ordeal.
Just going
back to the first thing you said
when you shook her hand
and you said that you were
there to take her home.
Did she know?
Obviously, she was on a plane.
So she knew something was happening.
Did she know for sure she was being freed
before that moment?
At that point, you did.
The Russians,
just like the United States,
has to go through certain
administrative procedures
at a certain point,
it kind of becomes evident that something
something's happening.
And then usually
when the Russians pick up
someone from their prison
cell, in this case, Brittany,
they give her a sense
that she's going home that day.
What's that
like to be the person
to shake someone's hand
and welcome them back to America
after they've been wrongly held?
It's humbling.
I'm very grateful
that President Biden
allows me a chance to do this job.
It's also a painful job.
So when you get the chance
to shake
someone's hands, it's
one of those rare moments
that you get to celebrate a victory
but know this.
Even as we're welcoming someone home,
we still have work to do.
So as I'm shaking Brittany's hands
and we're taking to the aircraft
and having this great conversation,
my brain is already thinking about
Paul Whalen.
What can we do to get him back?
What's our next move?
What's the strategy?
How can we adapt?
And I want to ask you that one second
just quickly. How's her physical health?
She's she looks great.
I mean, she was full of energy,
looked fantastic.
She's in Fort Sam Houston
right now, undergoing some
some medical evaluations.
But she seems to be just fine.
Okay, so let's talk about Paul Whalen.
What options realistically
do you have to bring him home?
I would love to tell you about it
because to me,
they're very exciting and interesting.
But we have to in these negotiations
because they're ongoing,
we usually have to keep our cards
close to. But are there cards?
There's always cards.
The options are always being evaluated.
We have to adapt at times
But here's the thing
I would like to leave you with.
We have an ongoing open dialog
with the Russians,
and we have the commitment
of this
president and my office
certainly to bring Paul Whalen home.
To my mind.
And I talked to Paul, by the way.
I may not have mentioned this,
but I talked to him on Friday,
the day after the swap.
And here's what I told him.
I said, Paul,
you have the commitment of this president
the president's focus,
the secretary of state's focused.
I'm certainly focused,
and we're going to bring you home.
And I reminded him,
I said, Paul, when you're in the Marines
and I was in the Army,
they always reminded you, keep the faith.
And I said, keep the faith.
We're coming to get you,
because I want
our viewers to listen to something.
He actually called
our colleague,
Jennifer Handler from the Russian prison.
And here's what he said to her.
I'm greatly disappointed
that more has not been done
to secure my release.
I'm happy that
Britney is going home today
and that Trevor went home when he did.
But I don't understand why
I'm still sitting here.
What's it like to hear that
I'm guessing he said similar to you?
He did.
He shared his frustration
and I explained him to him
that Paul,
this was a case where it was either
one or not.
We weren't able to get you out on this.
Go round.
We could not get the deal
with the Russians.
But had we not made the deal,
then you would not have come home.
There was no opportunity
to bring you home at this time.
But, Paul, we're coming for you.
And what do you say to people like
Senator Bob Menendez,
who's
the chairman of the Foreign
Relations Committee,
one of the president's fellow Democrats,
who said that
making that swap with Viktor
Bout was deeply disturbing.
He said, we must stop
inviting dictatorial and rogue
regimes to use Americans
overseas as bargaining chips.
Do you
I guess, how do you
respond to his argument
that this sends a message
to hostile countries
that all they need to do
is kidnap an American
to get what they want
Well, I'd say that it's important
to note that
people that are held
overseas are important to us.
And that's kind of the word I'd say.
I start
when I look at the question morally,
was it bad
to treat someone like Victor Boo?
I think the question is it's horrific
to leave an American wrongfully detained
in a foreign jail cell.
Is it going to incentivize
other bad actors?
Let me say this,
but there are bad actors.
We used to say the
the other side gets a vote.
And in this case, it's
hard to keep these dictators
and these dictatorial governments
as a chairman amendment,
Menendez said,
from taking Americans
and trying to use them
as bargaining chips.
But this is precisely why
this summer
the president signed an executive order
that provides us with new tools
to add a deterrence effect.
And additionally,
Secretary Blinken
has been working with other countries
to try to create a multilateral coalition
that can put this
I guess you could say this This
using Americans is
wrong wrongly
as bargaining chips, rather,
to put that on the dustbin of history.
So let me ask you about that,
because he did sign
the president did sign
an executive order.
And what it does is it
authorizes sanctions and visa bans
against people responsible for wrongly
wrongfully detaining Americans.
As far as we can tell,
it hasn't been used. Why not?
It hasn't yet.
I'll say this,
but sometimes you might be working
with the country
and you might have hostages
that you have to keep working out.
It may not be the right timing
and place to use a sanctioning authority.
But believe me, we're working
on target packages right now.
It's something that we discuss
all the time.
And it's not going to be too long
before you see something rolled out.
Well, for example,
the there's an African leaders
summit here in Washington coming up.
The State
Department says that
the president of Rwanda is wrongly,
wrongfully detaining
an American will be used.
These are these are
decisions that we're constantly
reevaluating and talking about.
I'd hate to get into future
talks about that
because these are things
that are constantly under negotiation.
And I'll just leave it at that, if I may.
I want to ask about the other families
and the other hostages who are out.
There are people who are
wrongfully detained.
The James Foley
Foundation says
that there are at least 60 Americans
wrongfully detained.
One of them is Austin Tice,
who is a former journalist
and a former Marine.
He was kidnaped in Syria
more than a year ago.
I know you personally traveled to Syria.
Any update on his situation?
Is he possibly going to come home soon?
We're still working on that.
Again, I hate to get into negotiations
and things that we're currently doing.
But as I've often told
Deborah Tice's mother, I'm optimistic.
I think there are always pass forward
that allow us to get an opportunity
to bring someone like Austin home.
Well, you have helped bring home
15 Americans
who were wrongfully detained
or held hostage in nine months.
That's a pretty good track record.
And we thank you so much for your service
and for coming out and telling the story.
Thank you for having me. On. Thank you.